there's no shortage of great horror
movies out there but there's also a
graveyard full of certified clunkers
just waiting to terrorize you with their
terribleness your with rich people
waiting I'm just here to buy groceries
rich we scoured Rotten Tomatoes to find
some of the worst horror movies ever
made and they aren't for the faint of
heart or pretty much anyone else for
that matter
please squash human centipede 3
newsflash all three installments of the
human centipede are absolutely awful
unless of course you like movies about
invasive butt surgery after torturing
audiences with the first two films in
the series director Tom six returned in
2015 to finish the job with the human
centipede 3 watching this film feels
like work but without the Paycheck or
health benefits dieter laser who played
the villainous surgeon in the first two
installments inexplicably returns as a
new equally hideous character a Texas
prison warden meanwhile our condolences
to Eric Roberts career is like its
predecessors the human centipede 3 lacks
substance style and any kind of smarts
to put it another way this movie will
make you feel like you're at the end of
the centipede this is exactly what
America needs the happening ain't
happening
[Music]
[Applause]
following the success of blockbusters
like The Sixth Sense and unbreakable M
night Shyamalan was considered
Hollywood's plot twist King but his
reputation took a twisty downturn after
lackluster responses to films like signs
the village and lady in the water still
the worst was yet to come
in 2008 Shyamalan released his first
r-rated film The Happening which starred
Mark Wahlberg as an unlikely science
teacher caught up in a biological
mystery mayhem is sweeping the country
and countless people take their own
lives and it's up to Wahlberg to figure
out what's going on and it's too bad he
did the big twist is the cinematic
equivalent of a belly flop the
population is being attacked by the
Earth's plants which is spreading the
toxin through the air to defend
themselves against destructive humans
unfortunately they only got their
revenge on moviegoers just going to talk
in a very positive manner giving off
good vibes we're just here to use the
bathroom Blair Witch 2 is cursed
in 1999 the Blair Witch Project took
audiences by storm birthing the
found-footage genre seizing on the
moment artisan entertainment
fast-tracked a sequel Book of Shadows
Blair Witch 2 the movie follows a group
of Blair Witch fanatics as they venture
out to the Black Hills to explore the
legend firsthand the film abandons the
tone of the first film opting for lots
of random violence that doesn't distract
from the fact that the film is a total
bore to make matters all the more
confusing Book of Shadows Blair Witch 2
doesn't actually feature a book of
shadows but it does feature time-travel
amateur psychics and this guy jaws the
revenge totally bites
jaw's the revenge this time it's
personal when a film's tagline is the
most creative part of a film you know
you're in dark waters a decade after
Steven Spielberg created the summer
blockbuster with jaws Universal released
jaws the revenge currently holding a
zero percent rating on Rotten Tomatoes
the film is arguably one of the worst
movies ever made trying to explain the
premise to the archive of American
television director Joseph Sargent can
barely get the words out that a shark
could could wreak vengeance for the
killing of his cousins or whatever they
were the film stars Lorraine Gary as
Ellen Brody the wife of the late Martin
Brody played by Roy Scheider in the
original film Ellen becomes convinced
her family is being stalked by a
vengeful shark and she's right odder
still this particular shark even roars
[Music]
Creepshow three just know 1982's
Creepshow was a delight from start to
finish the frequently fun anthology film
pairs up horror masters Stephen King and
George a Romero and it delivers plenty
of camp carnage and killer style it was
followed up in 1987 by the weaker but
still entertaining Creepshow - and then
in 2006 Creepshow 3 happened the film is
terrible which explains it's frightening
0% score on Rotten Tomatoes King and
Romero had nothing to do with this
schlock so instead of demonic
cockroaches and monsters and crates we
get this as legendary makeup artist Tom
Savini says tales from the darkside the
movie is the real creep show 3 so watch
that instead I want them but I
[Music]